et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Sylvain Maillard bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous député de tarif
vice-président du groupe Renaissance à
l'Assemblée nationale on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
bonjour Stéphane Vernet bonjour bonjour
Stéphane de westfrance on commence
évidemment par la dixième journée de
mobilisation Gérald Darmanin qui a donc
annoncé hier un dispositif de sécurité
inédit 13000 policiers gendarmes qui
sont déployés sur tout le territoire
dont 5500 à Paris est-ce que vous
redoutez que cette journée de
mobilisation ne se transforme en journée
de violence d'abord je le remercie parce
que on a besoin d'avoir des policiers
moi qui suis élu parisien ça devient une
angoisse comme on a connu dans d'autres
périodes une angoisse desquin une
manifestation parce que des black-box
des extrêmes gauche vient et casse tout
ce qui est tout ce qu'il y a sur le
parcours sur le parcours du de la
manifestation et Paris c'est aussi une
ville pas uniquement une ville de
manifestation c'est une ville aussi où
il y a des familles il y a des enfants
et donc vraiment cette déchaînement de
violence et pour nous aussi à chaque
fois un traumatisme je trouve qu'on en
parle pas assez ça on a l'impression
finalement tout passe tout est lisse oui
on élève aussi nos familles et on a des
familles on élève nos enfants aussi à
Paris et donc on a envie on doit aussi
avoir du calme et un relativement cette
fois aujourd'hui le ministre de
l'Intérieur alerte en disant qu'il y
aurait 1000 personnes
ultra violentes qui qui viendrait
rejoindre les manifestations en France
dont des gens qui viennent de l'étranger
parce qu'on est on n'est pas en train de
franchir un cap si c'est si c'est vrai
c'est déjà le cas la sainte solide on a
une d'organisation des blackbogs qui est
toujours un peu compliqué l'extrême
gauche qui communique sur le Dark Dark
web et est une nébuleuse très
internationale ce qu'on a demandé c'est
qu'on puisse en amont essayer de de les
arrêter vous savez la difficulté en
France j'entendais tout à l'heure notre
invité précédente en France on n'arrête
pas sur sur où on met pas en garde à vue
sur la bonne mine ou sur la couleur du
jogging qu'on soit clair on on arrête
parce que on regarde ce qu'il y a dans
les sacs à dos et on s'aperçoit qu'il y
a des balles de baseball des boules de
pétanque ou des haches ou des couteaux
ils sont ils s'organisent de plus en
plus en laissant le matériel sur place
et le récupère dans la rue cachée et le
récupère et donc c'est plus compliqué
l'avance exactement c'est plus compliqué
pour les forces de l'ordre parce que on
arrête pas les gens sur sur la couleur
de leur habits et heureusement vous
entendez l'opposition qui dit ça s'est
bien passé pendant huit journées là ça
se passe mal depuis deux journées hier à
votre place il y avait Sandrine Rousseau
qui a dit se demander s'il y avait pas
chez Gérald Darmanin et chez Emmanuel
Macron une volonté d'aller chercher
l'incident je la cite combien de vous je
trouve ça terrible comme phrase
honnêtement je trouve ça terrible
d'entendre ça au fond de renvoyer la
violence la violence des d'une toute
petite partie des manifestants je
confonds pas mais on parlait des Black
Box de l'extrême gauche et au fond de
dire qu'il y aurait comme un jeu entre
l'État et l'État le gouvernement et
cette violence non c'est l'extrême
gauche la théorisé de la violence dans
la société elle pense qu'elle peut à
accéder au pouvoir par la violence et
d'ailleurs l'extrême gauche politique
donc celle qu'on retrouve à l'Assemblée
nationale fait exactement la même chose
politique la nups
en particulier en cherchant en
permanence sur chaque sujet
listérisation pourquoi parce que dans
leur théorie dans leur théorie
d'ailleurs Jean-Luc Mélenchon on s'en
est jamais caché à la porte depuis
longtemps pour lui c'est l'extrême
tension de la société qui permettra
d'accéder au pouvoir et donc oui il
cherche en permanence à l'assembler
hystériser les débats de chaque mini
problème d'en faire d'en faire un buzz
sur les réseaux sociaux c'est leur
organisation et donc dans les
manifestations faire en sorte que ça se
passe mal vous êtes en train de nous
dire que cette volonté d'aller chercher
l'incident pour reprendre les mots de
Sandrine Rousseau il serait plutôt de
l'autre côté en face chez les
professionnels de la violence les gens
radicalisés ultra bien quand vous venez
à Sainte Soline avec des couteaux des
des haches vous avez vu vous avez vu les
images vos confrères vos confrères qui
ont été
caillassées ont eu peur pour leur vie
vous voyez bien que c'est pas les
policiers qui est après qui est des
réactions parfois des policiers qui sont
inadaptés j'en conviens et il faut que
ce soit sanctionné enfin les policiers
c'est dur alors leur policiers gendarme
le travail est extrêmement difficile et
renvoyer les uns aux autres honnêtement
et c'est insupportable la gauche pointe
la stratégie du maintien de l'ordre
notamment avec ce qui s'est passé à
Sainte Soline il demande une commission
d'enquête à l'Assemblée nationale vous
êtes favorable on peut tout regarder et
nous regarder ce que fait comment
s'organiser extrême gauche on est aussi
en train de réfléchir dessus ce qu'on
peut faire
on est en train de réfléchir on regarde
si concrètement comprendre comment ça
fonctionne extrême gauche
l'extrême sur l'extrême gauche violente
des Black Box comment ils font pour se
financer enfin vous voyez il y a des
questions sur lesquelles il faut qu'on
puisse
on réfléchit à l'heure actuelle savoir
ce que comment comment y répondre les
commissions d'enquête suffit pas d'aller
sur un plateau de télévision il faut que
ce soit un support juridique
construit mais mais oui parce que on
voudrait comprendre ce qui se passe
exactement qu'est-ce qui se passe
je soupçonnais l'extrême gauche
d'entretenir ça bien sûr on voit bien on
voit bien qu'il y a forcément des liens
des liens et renvoyer les uns aux autres
en expliquant qu'au fond le gouvernement
aurait intérêt à ce que ça se passe mal
c'est c'est une erreur d'abord politique
mais en plus c'est une faute morale
évidemment que nous notre intérêt c'est
que il y ait des manifestants passent
plutôt bien parce que c'est un droit à
manifester parce que si jamais ça
partait dans des débordements absolus
évidemment ce serait plutôt en
difficulté donc moi je crois je crois
que le le l'histérisation est arrivé un
peu à son paroxysme à l'heure actuelle
et d'arrêter de renvoyer une sorte de
violence les uns contre les autres c'est
l'extrême gauche l'extrême gauche oui
Hollande dans la rue qui cherche la
société il y a aussi on manifesté très
bien par à Paris comme ailleurs depuis
des semaines dès que les syndicats s'en
occupaient et ça se passait très très
bien une fois que les syndicats
n'étaient plus forcément parfaitement
mettre de la situation c'est là où ça
parle ils ne sont plus mettre de la
situation aujourd'hui pour Paris on le
voit bien il y a deux cortèges cortège
qui est tenu par les les manifestes les
syndicats et ça se passe plutôt bien
mais mais dès que dès que les Black Box
arrivent c'est plus de nuit on parlait
de politique de maintien de l'ordre
est-ce qu'il y a un des problématiques
du maintien de l'ordre en France
aujourd'hui c'est que on a des forces de
l'ordre qui n'arrivent pas à séparer en
fait ces Black Blocs de des manifester
citoyens qui viennent manifester en fait
on a l'impression que la réponse des
forces de l'ordre n'est pas différenciée
ils arrivent pas en fait à cibler les
éléments perturbateurs et fauteur de
troubles et les gens qui sont qui
génèrent des violences du manifestant
lambda entre c'est ça la technique des
black-box c'est-à-dire d'être capable de
faire une opération très vite très forte
se massifier et d'attaquer et de partir
de se fondre dans la masse c'est ça là
donc évidemment c'est compliqué d'avoir
une réponse policière si les black-box
arrivent ou l'extrême gauche arrive d'or
des syndicats empêcher les Black Blocs
de s'infiler ça fonctionnait aujourd'hui
ça c'est ça c'est plus difficile c'est
plus compliqué donc honnêtement le
travail des policiers des gendarmes est
extrêmement difficile est-ce que tout
est parfait évidemment que non et on a
vu quelques exemples mais il faut voir
qu'ils se font caillasser ils ont peur
ils sont des des pères et des maires de
famille aussi ils peuvent avoir aussi
peur même s'il reste très professionnel
la fatigue tout ça fait que c'est
compliqué normalement de on n'a pas dans
une manifestation à caillasser on n'a
pas à harceler les forces de l'ordre des
forces de l'ordre elles sont juste là
pour garantir le fait qu'on ait droit de
manifester donc nous arrêtons de
retourner en permanence la situation
c'est c'est manifestants violents qui
viennent harceler les forces de l'or
sinon toute manifestation passe
parfaitement bien il y a une pétition
pour dissoudre les braves aiment sur le
site de l'Assemblée nationale quelqu'un
qui a recueilli plus de 100 000
signatures c'est un record depuis la
mise en place de ce système est-ce que
la commission des lois de l'Assemblée
doit s'en saisir dès maintenant
ça c'est
de décider que les forces de police au
fond seraient responsable du fait que il
y ait des casseurs rue Saint-Marc pas
très loin d'ici quand on a brûlé quand
on a commencé à brûler un immeuble il y
a pas très longtemps quelques jours avec
du monde à l'intérieur c'est c'est les
policiers qui étaient là non ce sont des
manifestants d'extrême gauche des Black
Box qui était là pour allumer et puis
avec d'autres qui filmaient parce qu'il
trouvait ça super c'est ça la réalité
donc arrêtons de de chercher des
responsables qui ne sont pas là où ils
sont les responsables de du chaos ce
sont les Black Box et tout ce qui
entoure l'ultra gauche donc cette
pétition pour le moment
où on ne souhaitait que rien ne soit
fait avec
non mais enfin chacun fait ce qu'il veut
mon souci c'est que les manifestants
puissent s'ils souhaitent manifester
manifester dans le calme en France on
n'est pas on n'est pas en train de je
pense qu'il y a des temporalités pour
tout on peut toujours réfléchir comment
on organise mieux les forces de l'ordre
et ça c'est évidemment toujours ouvert à
ça y compris
est-ce qu'il faut revoir le système de
fonctionnement de ces braves
c'est au préfet de police qui est le
spécialiste et qui qui sait comment il
fonctionne c'est ces hommes et ces
femmes qui sont sous ses ordres mais
mais le à l'heure actuelle le danger
les problèmes que nous avons dans la rue
c'est pas les policiers ce sont ce sont
encore une fois à gauche l'ultra gauche
qui qui
ultra gauche les Black Box qui attaquent
est-ce que vous avez dans un faux
particulières sur la mobilisation des
jeunes les lycéens les étudiants les
blocages est-ce que c'est quelque chose
qui est en train de monter à votre dans
votre connaissance écoutez oui on voit
moi j'ai compris à Paris et dans ma
circonscription des des lycées qui sont
régulièrement bloqués donc c'est tout de
plus en plus en tout cas qui sont
maintenant régulièrement donc j'ai pas
de chiffres là particulière à vous
donner mais mais cette mobilisation de
la jeunesse en tout cas on est on est
sensibilisé oui c'est toujours
16 ans qui commencent à manifester ils
sont plus difficiles évidemment encadrés
dans des manifestations et quand il y a
des manifestants violents dont on vient
de parler qui sont en plus en même dans
le même endroit bah écoutez comme chacun
d'entre nous chaque père et mère de
famille il y a toujours une vraie source
d'inquiétude il y a plus d'un monde
français dans les rues en tout cas
c'était le cas jeudi dernier c'est une
mobilisation qui ne s'essouffle pas il y
a encore des centaines de milliers de
Français qui sont attendus aujourd'hui
il y a des grèves dans les secteurs des
transports de l'énergie pourquoi ne pas
écouter Laurent Berger et mettre la
réforme sur pause on nous avons besoin
de cette réforme on a toujours dit c'est
une réforme un peu populaire on le sait
très bien et on les on l'a su dès qu'on
l'a porté pendant l'élection
présidentielle puis législatives on a
perdu des députés avec cette réforme
parce qu'on a porté cela j'ai bien vu
moi titre personnel quand je l'ai porté
pendant les élections en juin dernier
j'ai vu à quel point c'était difficile
c'est une réforme un peu plus elle
demande un effort à ceux qui le peuvent
aux Français ceux qui le peuvent en tout
cas de travailler de travailler plus
donc oui elle est forcément un peu plus
comme l'été celle d'avant mais on nous
en avons besoin pour équilibrer notre
système est sûr que les pensions soient
payées dans le temps
nous avons besoin donc nous nous avons
besoin donc nous irons jusqu'au bout
elle a été adoptée à l'ASSE et au Sénat
nous la mettrons nous la promulguerons
quand nous recevrons la vie conforme de
conseil constitutions
mais pourquoi ne pas faire de pause
faire une pause c'est pas retirer la
réforme accéder à la demande de Laurent
Berger les syndicats par exemple
qu'est-ce que propose Laurent Berger en
fait
nous la CFDT comme tous les autres
syndicats on les a reçu beaucoup je
portais le texte à l'Assemblée nationale
on les a reçus pendant plusieurs
semaines ils ne veulent pas de ça de du
changement de 62 à 64 ans c'est une
ligne rouge pour eux tout le reste
toutes les améliorations parce que tout
ce qu'on a voté à côté ce ne sont que
des améliorations du système à l'heure
actuelle beaucoup plus favorable les
demandes des forces et les deux ans
supplémentaires ils refusent ces deux
ans donc de toute façon dans 6 mois dans
6 mois ce sera exactement la même chose
qu'est-ce qu'on fait continuer
le courage politique c'est aussi de dire
on entend
de vos réticences mais on estime que
pour le pays pour sauvegarder à moyen et
long terme les pensions c'est nécessaire
de le faire et on prend et au fond on
accepte de prendre nous l'impopularité
mais le plan le plan d'action proposé
par Elisabeth borne le fait de
renégocier avec l'ensemble des
partenaires sociaux à quoi ça sert parce
que il est question de parler tout un
tas de séries de toute une série pardon
de sujets annexes mais qui sont déjà des
choses qui sont étudiées dans le cadre
par exemple du Conseil national de la
refondation quelle est la nouveauté à
quoi ça sert à un moment il faut les
rentrer dans la loi on n'a pas un
planning donc la négociation que nous
voulons rentrer entre les partenaires
sociaux sur le partage de la valeur que
nous voulons rentrer dans la loi on veut
aussi sur
la base c'est à dire qu'il y aura une
proposition de loi une proposition là où
le projet de loi on est en train de
regarder avec
la majorité présidentielle la majorité
des associations en train de regarder
les éléments qui sont déjà négociés et
qu'on pourrait faire rentrer directement
dans la loi mais on est différents
sujets du Conseil national c'est ça bien
sûr mais donc la négociation qui a été
faite la nuit a été
partagé
que ça rentre en valeur rapidement
de la faire rentrer dans la loi que ce
soit un projet de loi une proposition de
loi on va regarder dans les jours qui
viennent
le le ce qui est le projet le plus la
façon de la plus efficace de le porter
mais nous avons aussi d'autres domaines
dans lesquels nous voulons avancer Bruno
Le Maire a beaucoup parlé du dividende
salarié mais il y a d'autres objets
politiques sur lesquels il est temps
d'avancer aussi moi je porte aussi des
idées sur le télétravail il va falloir
qu'on avance aussi sur probablement
alors d'autres d'autres éléments sur
lesquels moi aussi je travaille sur
comment faire en sorte que on est plus
accès aux
parents au parc social ou aux actions
dans les entreprises dans les petites et
moyennes entreprises on parle toujours
des grandes entreprises mais comment on
fait pour avoir plus facilement accès à
des
tous ces objets là qui permettent de
partager la vallée
et le président de l'entreprise et les
mêmes intérêts que l'ensemble de ces
salariés donc nous ça nous semble un axe
intéressant ce sera dans la loi travail
vous préparez un texte à part on est en
train de regarder on regarde les
différents objets qu'on peut porter s'il
faut déjà aller travailler d'un point de
vue juridique et puis consensuel avec
les partenaires sociaux donc c'est pour
ça qu'on les demande aussi de revenir
autour de la table pour pouvoir discuter
et ensuite on verra quel est le meilleur
vecteur juridique c'est au fond c'est
pas très très important l'essentiel
c'est qu'on acte avec les partenaires
sociaux les tels ou tel point qui nous
semblent essentiels pour qu'on puisse
changer la donne rapidement dans le
monde du travail parce qu'on l'a entendu
pendant les manifestations on continue à
l'entendre il y a pas que le fait de
travailler deux ans de plus c'est le
travailler mieux comment on fait pour
mieux travailler en France à l'heure
actuelle dans les entreprises c'est ça
qu'on entend beaucoup dans les
manifestations
en fait qui montre que la popularité
d'Emmanuel Macron est en étant chute
moins six mois 6 points 30% des
personnes sont dépenses qu'il ferait un
bon président donc il est un bon
président qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire
ça fait jamais plaisir d'avoir une
baisse de popularité du chef de l'État
en même temps
je sais pas trop à fonctionner avec les
nez dans les sondages ça monte ça
descend je crois que on est dans une
phase oui bon on l'a connu oui bien sûr
mais peut-être vous me inviterez ça
augmentera dans quelques semaines je
crois que ce qui est important c'est
c'est la cote de popularité fonctionne
beaucoup avec aussi
le climat social qui m'a social est
difficile à l'heure actuelle donc c'est
pas c'est pas étonnant que la cote de
popularis soit plus soit plus compliqué
à l'heure actuelle
comment est-ce qu'on sort de la crise
je crois il est texte consensuel des
textes qui améliorent à la qualité de
vie au travail par exemple de ce dont on
vient de parler et des textes où on
arrive à trouver une majorité plus
simple à l'Assemblée nationale on voit
bien que c'est compliqué pour nous moi
qui suis député
de renaissance trouver des majorités
devient de plus en plus difficiles on
est en face de nous des oppositions qui
au fond
quelles que soient le sujet par nature
s'oppose à ce que l'on porte d'autant
plus d'efforts
depuis le début du quinté on retient que
les trois qui sont pas passés on a
trouvé des majorités pour tout on a
trouvé des majorités pour tous les
textes c'est vrai en commission mix
paritaire c'est toutes les tous les
textes sont passés par les budgétaires
sont passés en commission mixte
paritaire donc entre les sénateurs et
les et les députés à chaque fois on a
trouvé un accord ce qu'on avait pas dans
les législatures précédentes donc à
chaque fois on arrive à trouver des
accords mais là ça va être plus dur
bah écoutez sur les retraites de convoi
ou quand on voit que même les
républicains nous lâchent pour une
partie d'entre eux en rase campagne
alors qu'ils l'ont toujours porté y
compris ici au Sénat c'est vrai que
c'est un peu étonnant donc ça va
demander d'encore plus d'efforts enfin
on y est prêt sauf que la vingtaine de
textes qui qui sont qui est passé
jusqu'à maintenant c'était le fruit de
négociation de d'accord parlementaires
enfin de d'une méthode qui fonctionnait
à priori mais le texte sur la réforme
des retraites elle-même ça devait être
le point d'orgue de cette méthode et la
démonstration en faisant passer le texte
normalement entre guillemets que le la
chose fonctionnait le cet échec là ce
qui marque pas le la fin la fin
définitive de cette méthode alors
honnêtement je le vis pas comme ça c'est
pas un point d'orgue c'est chaque texte
on cherche une majorité
dans le texte on réfléchit comment on
fait pour construire une majorité par
exemple le texte sur l'énergie
on a décidé de le scinder en deux avec
une partie énergie renouvelable puis un
autre texte sur le nucléaire parce qu'on
voit bien que c'était impossible de
trouver une majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale sur l'intégralité du texte ça
c'est votre nouvelle méthode c'est la
méthode qu'on utilise depuis le mois de
en fait juillet août immigration et donc
c'est pour ça aussi que ben voilà ça
fait partie il nous faut des objets des
textes plus courts
cinq articles
voilà et qui soit où on arrive à
identifier très rapidement ça ça peut
marcher
parce qu'on entend les parlementaires
qui disent on peut pas avoir trois
politiques d'immigration on peut pas
faire du en même temps sur l'immigration
je ne suis pas d'accord avec ça je pense
que sur certains objets politiques par
exemple sur sur l'immigration c'est je
trouve ça c'est un sujet qui est qui est
extrêmement fort sur les
qui en autorise à rester en France on
voit bien que sur si on décide que on
puisse avoir des autorisations pour ceux
qui travaillent
on aura plus facilement
des majorités peut-être alors ça dépend
de la construction du texte peut-être
plus à gauche et puis si on est plus dur
sur les retours aux frontières bah plus
facilement à droite vous voyez donc il y
a un moment il y a ça peut être une
politique et qui est la nôtre au fond
c'est ce qu'on a toujours porté c'est
délire être plus ferme beaucoup plus
ferme avec ceux qui n'ont pas le droit
de rester en France par contre ceux qui
sont en France mieux les accueillir
toujours mieux les accueillir un mot sur
les menaces envers les élus et les
parlementaires qui sont visés il y a
notamment eu Aurore berger votre
président de groupe et elle brune Pivet
qui ont fait état de menaces sur leurs
enfants et elles vont une fille qui a
également suit des menaces antisémites
alors au-delà de la condamnation
évidemment importante est-ce qu'il faut
renforcer les sanctions envers les
auteurs de ces menaces oui déjà faut
j'aimerais bien qu'on les identifie
parce qu'on voit que c'est un peu
toujours les mêmes qui écrit en tout cas
on reconnaît un peu toujours
malheureusement la même pas donc il faut
déjà vraiment je demande évidemment
confiance dans la justice la police mais
vraiment qu'on les identifie et et oui
renforcer les punir les traduire devant
les tribunaux et dire et redire à votre
micro on porte plainte systématiquement
nous demandons à chaque nos élus
Renaissance à chaque fois de porter
plainte et vraiment nous le faisons à
chaque fois donc ceux qui
font ce type de de ce type de d'horreur
qu'il sache qu'il risque j'espère qu'ils
seront confrontés à la justice qui le
sache
peut-être un mot sur la situation à
Paris la grève des poubelles c'est
actuellement c'est plus de 7000 tonnes
de déchets accumulés dans les rues
comment on sort de cette crise là
comment on comment on fait vous avez
sachant que vous avez on voit passer les
messages de gens qui disent ben on va
continuer ça va durer et on va faire en
sorte de pourrir les Jeux Olympiques
l'année prochaine qu'est-ce que ça vous
inspire bon alors à court terme je pense
qu'il n'y a goût elle nous a mis dans le
mur je vais dire très clairement écoutez
quand elle commence à afficher sur sa
mairie qu'elle soutient les manifestants
et quand on lui demande de
réquisitionner quand Gérald Darmanin lui
demande de réquisitionner un minimum
pour que ça puisse tourner elle dit non
non moi je ferais rien elle soutient les
bloqueurs parce que qu'est-ce qui se
passe en fait on a entre deux et 6% de
de grévis seulement dans les dans les à
l'heure actuelle dans le nettoiement de
Paris si pour ça pas beaucoup au maximum
6 %, mais pourquoi il bloque deux choses
il bloque les incinérateurs donc pour
empêcher de vider les bennes et il
bloque les garages où sont marqués les
camions ben pour empêcher la sortie en
fait en bloquant
ça empêche les collègues mais parce que
sinon
quasiment l'intégralité quasiment des
autres sont prêts et travail d'ailleurs
on voit on voit nos éboueurs qui
travaillent dans la rue avec des ballets
qui continuent à côté mais qui collecte
plus le les poubelles
gouvernement avec la réforme d'après
elle s'est enférée dans une dans une
sorte de soutien absolu elle oublie
qu'elle est maire de Paris en fait elle
pense qu'elle est encore candidate donc
je crois que les Français ont décidé
l'ont mis un niveau qui doit faire en
sorte que ces aspirations nationales
redescendre rapidement et elle s'occupe
elle est maire de Paris elle doit
s'occuper des Parisiens c'est ce qu'on
lui a demandé ce qu'on lui demande elle
est la mère des Parisiens donc elle doit
s'occuper trouver des solutions et donc
moi ce salut je l'avais demandé à Gérald
Darmanin et au préfet de police de
réquisitionner continuer à l'acquisition
il y a que ça qui fonctionne faire en
sorte que ces deux nœuds là dont on
vient de parler ne soit plus bloqué même
si ça se bloque ça se Reba il faut à
chaque fois réquisitionner pour empêcher
le
à Paris on a d'autres problèmes de
problématique mais nous on dit OUI OUI
au free flotting mais réguler il faut
évidemment beaucoup plus de sanctions et
et d'organisation autour du feu
arrière d'avoir été notre invité la
ligne de Ouest-France garde à l'hôpital
la fin des intérims délirants c'est à la
Une de votre journal Stéphane merci
Stéphane merci Sylvain